[Musique]
on va poursuivre la discussion avec Eric
parent et les PDG de votre technologie
experts en cyber sécurité bonsoir
Monsieur parents
alors comment ça fonctionne exactement
le genestis Market cette plateforme
grande plateforme on dit l'une des plus
dangereuses du monde d'ailleurs c'est ce
que disait Europa aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
que c'est exactement
mais en plus imaginer que on voulait
faire un crime en groupe il faut se
rencontrer que port de trésor un endroit
très sécuritaire dans un bar mal éclairé
des choses qu'on voit dans les cinémas
avec jeunesse Market mais c'était la
plateforme électronique pour
essentiellement arriver à ce genre de
d'environnement là c'est une plateforme
sur invitation plateforme contrôlée ou
qu'on peut aller on peut l'imaginer
comme étant le eBay de monde criminalisé
ou qu'on peut aller publier des choses
offrir des listes de d'informations
volées et puis échanger des choses
finalement faire des transactions est-ce
qu'on connecte quel type d'informations
ont été volés et
pour exactement
d'assurance sociale des dates de
naissance ça peut même inclure des
numéros de carte de crédit de dépendant
d'où les informations ont été volées et
c'est ces choses-là qui vont être
changées des fois pour les réassembler
alors si on a juste un nom à l'adresse
un numéro de d'assurance sociale et que
quelqu'un d'autre a un nom et une date
de naissance et une carte de crédit
quand on requie est toute son ensemble
on finit par avoir un dossier complet et
là le prix aussi change alors quand on
ajoute des listes plus simples ça peut
être 70 sous le dossier mais si on a
quelque chose de complet avec des
numéros 4 de crédit et puis des comptes
bancaires ça pourrait être dans les
quelques dollars par dossier oui mais ça
nous semble quand même des sommes
dérisoires monsieur parent qu'on donne
accès pour 77 américains à une personne
qui est vulnérable de qui on peut tirer
profit si on est un criminel c'est donc
on présume très rentable pour ces
organisations
si on réussit à prendre un identité et
que ça nous a coûté si on y va avec
l'exemple de 70 sous et qu'on peut faire
une transaction de 1500 2000 3000
dollars sur une fausse carte de crédit
qui a été attribuée à cette victime mais
c'est sûr qu'un gain qui est très
intéressant le problème qui demeure
c'est un problème que la société va
vouloir va devoir régler on a un
problème d'identité numérique on a un
problème de responsabilité de
rehaussement de l'infrastructure
bancaire alors c'est bien beau de dire
aux gens faites attention de ne pas
exposer votre date de naissance et vos
numéros de sens social mais c'est numéro
2 ces informations-là ont été exposés
tellement de fois que ce n'est pas des
secrets alors faut que ça soit plus
difficile d'aller chercher une nouvelle
carte de crédit c'est ça l'enjeu
aujourd'hui c'est un enjeu qui est le
problème repose toujours sur les
citoyens
souvent on nous dit soyez vigilants
vérifiez l'état de vos comptes changer
vos mots de passe on veut
responsabilités les gens c'est une
partie de la solution lorsque je
comprends votre propos c'est qu'il doit
peut-être tenir des gens des
institutions responsables à les mêmes
jusqu'à des sanctions comment il faut
changer le système
dire aux gens de faire attention de ces
ridicule on peut pas demander à toutes
nos citoyens des experts en
cybersécurité puis de faire attention
alors c'est gentil de le dire c'est
naturel de dire aux gens regardez vos
relevés bancaires pour voir s'il y a une
fraude mais il est trop tard s'il y a
une fraude et puis les banques ou les
organisations ils vont toujours vous
donner de la protection comme Équifax ce
n'est pas une protection et qui fax va
vous le dire une fois que votre dossier
a été violé finalement alors c'est c'est
pas une protection une protection ça
empêcherait l'événement de ce produit
alors les sanctions si on avait des
sanctions qui va plus loin que
l'entreprise étant donné une pénalité de
100000 dollars à une banque pour une
brèche de sécurité ça paraît même pas
dans le chiffre d'affaires mais si on
prend un pourcentage du salaire des
dirigeants avec une loi qui serait bien
orchestrée là pour le faire pour rendre
les gens responsables vous jour au
lendemain ça serait des comités qui sera
formés et puis miraculeusement on
travaillerait vraiment sérieusement sur
le problème parce que là même si on ne
démantelé cette plateforme genestis
market ce que je comprends c'est que on
enlève une des grandes organisations
pour les pirates informatiques mais on
présume qu'il y en a d'autres est-ce que
c'est assez répandu ça sur le Dark web
par exemple
nos services de police exemple on a des
gens extrêmement compétents à la Sûreté
du Québec et le problème c'est qu'on a
plus de dossiers qu'on a deux personnes
alors des déco comme ça on vient de
fermer un centre d'achat finalement
d'informations c'est merveilleux il y en
a beaucoup qui dort pas très bien ce
soir parce que évidemment en faisant ces
perquisitions là ils vont retrouver des
liens avec d'autres gens il y a sûrement
d'autres gens qui vont potentiellement
avoir la visite de la police mais ça va
revenir c'est un peu un jeu de chat et
de souris on disait ma collègue Marc
Claude disait à peu près 500 millions de
dollars de perte liées à la
cybercriminalité monsieur parent est-ce
que ça vous semble raisonnable on serait
plutôt dans une échelle de milliards de
dollars au Canada
c'est difficile à chiffrer mais je peux
vous dire que si c'est le chiffre qu'on
a réussi à ressortir le vrai chiffre est
plus haut parce qu'il y a un côté
d'orgueil et puis de d'apparence avec
une banque qui s'est perdent un million
dans une fraude ils ne sont pas pressés
d'aller le dire aux médias ils peuvent
passer à côté ils vont passer à côté
alors quand on est des statistiques
comme les nombres de citoyens qui sont
faits avoir disons par un attaque
d'amsonage mais ça c'est ceux qui ont
bien voulu le rapporter la majorité des
gens sont peut-être inconscients ou son
gêné alors c'est sûr que les chiffres
sont plus haut dossier à suivre donc
merci beaucoup pour vos explications
monsieur parent bienvenue bonne soirée
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]